des milliers de jeunes lycéens
collégiens également des écoles
primaires étaient présents lors de
l'ouverture du salon régional de la
jeunesse qui se tient les 26 27 et 28
novembre à la nordev quatre salons en
ans puisque les jeunes avaient le choix
entre le salon régional de l'orientation
de la formation professionnelle de
l'apprentissage de la mobilité des
rencontres super content reprise du
salon d'éducation et de la fête de la
science à la maman vice-président
conseil départemental étaient présents
pour cette inauguration et enfin
logements par an
c'est s'occuper des jeunes nous avons
besoin existe comme important des jeunes
qui s'engagent
ce qui m'importe c'est que cette
jeunesse bien l'enfant elle elle prend
dans ses capacités
elle croit qu'elle qu'elle est porteuse
d'avenir pour elle même mais aussi pour
son pays ce qui importe pour moi c'est
la jeunesse croit dans la réunion c'est
pourquoi est ce que la jeunesse qu'on a
de la république avec les événements qui
sont arrivés c'est ainsi on a besoin
d'avoir une jeunesse responsable
battante gagnants différents stands dont
pour s'informer sur tous les dispositifs
mis en place en direction de la jeunesse
parmi ceux-ci ch le département qui
accompagne les étudiants à la réunion
mais également aux mobilités
oui ça m'a vraiment été sa marque à
l'éclair si les sites et sur ce qu'on
peut avoir ce qui est réalisable ou pas
réalisable donc oui ça oui c'est
vraiment vous centralisez on a tout ce
qu'on veut des écoles d'ingénieurs ou
dut ou s'est appelée vraiment tous les
secteurs ici c'est vraiment intéressant
si on veut
découvrir un peu question après le bac
oui beaucoup d'infos et pour après après
mon bac si je peux avoir une bourse ou
pas mais après là je vais voir pour les
transports par balles et le transport
gratuit
oui oui beaucoup d'infos quand même des
aides mises en place dans le cadre d'un
dispositif n'est bourse d'une plateforme
unique où les étudiants peuvent trouver
un certain nombre d'informations quand
ceux qui sont en formation initiale avec
différents partenaires et nous plus
particulièrement au conseil
départemental nous allons donner des
informations sur tous nos dispositifs
d'être en direction des étudiants
que ce soit la bourse et pimpante à la
location scolarité ou les logements à la
cité internationale universitaire paris
dz pour pouvoir réussir ses études mais
également des moyens de déplacement avec
la carte réuni passe pour se déplacer
sur toute l'île
un stand car jaune et un agent qui a pu
répondre aux attentes de notre future
étudiante réussir de 7 à 77 ans est le
leitmotiv de ce salon régional de la
jeunesse a priori pas seulement réservé
aux plus jeunes mais à tous ceux qui
souhaitent découvrir des orientations
différentes quel que soit leur âge comme
ici en souffleur de verre qui pourrait
éveiller des vocations